in King you control a group of warriors
each with different skills and abilities
how you choose to equip and improve them
makes all the difference between
surviving long enough to take out all
the bosses and unravel the mysteries of
this world or not at the start of the
game you have two warriors that you
control RAM and Ulrich and then others
join as you play through for a total of
six this makes up your pack of warriors
but alas as we all know not all six
packs ha created equal so here are the
top four things you need to know to make
the most of your six pack each warrior
has three abilities that you can bestow
upon them mind body and control
increasing mind will turn the hero into
a formidable magician strengthening the
body will make your hero a powerful
warrior and control turns your hero into
a cunning coordinated ranger or assassin
in King you are free to rebalance your
hero abilities whenever you are not in
combat so you can adjust to any
situation kin throws your way each
ability has a specific skill tree when
you complete a mission you are awarded
points and these can be spent against
abilities for each 15 points invested in
an ability you unlock a new tier of
skills basic skills range from healing
spells to tactical crowd control or all
around may
in the game there is a special skill
slot reserved for feed skills feed
skills are formed by combining a feed
stone with certain skills like their
name suggests feed stones feed on
specific energies in the world for
example the deathstone feeds on death
while the life stone feeds on life you
can unleash the powerful feed skill once
the stone is full feed stones range from
quite common to extremely rare and tough
to obtain a true hero needs armor and
weapons that complement his abilities if
for some reason you can't find the
equipment you need on the stinking
corpse of a deceased enemy you are
always free to craft your own each piece
of equipment in the world can be crafted
by finding the right components there
are over 90 crafting components
available thus even the most picky hero
can create something he likes
armor and weapons aside what's the point
in having a great-looking six-pack if
you don't know how to use it properly
while most enemies don't look
particularly intelligent they can make
your life harder than you would expect
so working your warriors as a team is
paramount to surviving some of the
trickier enemies you'll face if your
efforts are just not paying off and you
find yourself falling short then there's
only one option slow down time that's
more like it the advantage of tactical
time manipulation it makes all the
difference so there you have it a few
little hints on how to make the most of
your six-pack adventure on drave
adventurer kin is calling